We want to thank Google's Science Journal App for supporting PBS Digital Studios.
Imagine you had a time machine and with the
press of a button you could transport yourself
to your own 75th birthday.
Assuming you’re still around, what do you
hope to find yourself doing?
Writing your memoirs?
Sailing around the world?
Partying in San Junipero?
Very few of us would answer “cleaning toilets
at a fast-food joint,” or “begging for
change on the street.”
No one wants their story to end that way,
yet shockingly few of us are taking the basic
steps to avoid it.
The
simple fact is that if we’re lucky to live
long enough, one day we will lose our desire
(or physical ability) to keep earning a paycheck.
The older we get, the harder it becomes to
maintain a rigid work schedule.
And as modern medicine allows us to live longer
and longer, the time we expect to spend in
retirement might easily pass 30 years.
Think of that for a second.
30 years without income.
Nervous yet?
Good.
So how much would you need to not spend those
years in abject poverty.
Well, that depends on your personal needs,
standard of living, health issues, etc., but
as a starting point, the AARP recommends that
to replace a $40,000 per year income for 30
years, you’ll need to start your retirement
with--take a deep breath--$1.18 million.
If that number makes you feel a little dizzy…
well, you’re not alone.
In one survey, Americans between 55 and 64
reported a median retirement savings of $120,000--only
10% of the amount advised by the AARP!
Another survey found that 75% of Americans
over 40 are behind saving for retirement and
28% over 55 have no retirement savings at
all!
There are many factors that contributed to
this problem.
For one thing, wage growth declined in the
70s and 80s.
It picked back up in the 90s, but then the
housing boom convinced a lot of Americans
to go into debt to buy overpriced homes, and,
well, we know how that turned out.
We’ve also seen an increase in cultural
pressure to show “visual displays of wealth.”
A study published in the Quarterly Journal
of Economics suggests that Americans are uniquely
concerned about seeming poor to others, so
they spend a disproportionate amount on things
like shoes, clothes and cars.
It’s been great business for designer labels
and advertisers--not so much for our savings
accounts.
Lastly, changes in government policies have
made it easier to not save money.
In the past, employees were automatically
enrolled in “defined benefit plans” with
pre-set funding amounts to match their retirement
needs.
Today’s workers have to “opt in” to
retirement plans like 401(k)s, and figure
out for themselves how much to set aside.
Furthermore, these plans are often “leaky,”
meaning you’re allowed to remove funds prematurely,
which makes it easy to steal from your own
retirement.
Does all this mean that saving for retirement
is hopeless and you should just blow your
extra dough leasing a sports car?
No!
It’s still very possible to save up large
amounts of money on a modest income.
The three special ingredients are Good Markets,
Compound Interest, and Time.
To show you how these elements work together,
it’s time to…
RUN THE NUMBERS!
Betty is 30 years old and makes $50,000/yr.
She hasn’t saved a dime for retirement yet,
but this year she’s decided to start.
Between the amount she is going to save into
her Roth IRA, her 401(k) at work, and her
401(k) match, she’s putting away $625 a
month, or $7,500 a year, That’s 15% of her
income--which many experts recommend as a
good savings target.
At this rate, by the time she’s 65, Betty
will have personally deposited $262,500 into
her retirement account.
Impressive, but still a long way from the
million dollars plus she’ll need to retire.
But now we add our special ingredients!
Over the last 90 years, the stock market has
grown an average of 9.8% per year.
But let’s assume a little less than that…
say, 7.5% If Betty can put together a decent
portfolio, she can expect her savings to grow
by an average of 7.5% per year.
And as long as Betty doesn’t touch that
account, the dividends and interest she earns
will generate even more dividends and interest!
And over time, her savings doesn’t just
increase in a straight line… it increases
exponentially!
Now, by the time she’s 65, that $262,500
of her original money has ballooned to $1,277,158.92.
Nice job Betty!
A couple things to keep in mind with this
scenario.
It’s very likely that goods and services
will cost more in the future due to inflation.
However, it’s also very likely that a 30
year old like Betty will see her salary increase
as she gains more experience and skill.
If she sticks to that same 15% of her salary,
she can expect to have even more set aside
for retirement.
What if you’re older than Betty and getting
a late start?
Well, that may mean that you need to set aside
more of your paycheck, say 20 or 25 percent.
Or you may have to wait until your 70s to
retire.
Either of these options is better than doing
nothing or counting on winning the lottery.
There are many other factors that can change
your specific situation.
Inheritances, social security, pensions, medical
conditions.
If you’re not sure where to begin, you can
seek out the help of a financial planner who
is a sworn fiduciary.
They can outline a plan that fits your needs
and show you that preparing for retirement
is not as intimidating as you may think.
You don’t have to be into shuffleboard or
bird-watching to expect a little time off
in your golden years.
And some people want to work as long as they
can.
But everyone wants the power to decide that
for themselves, especially after a lifetime
of hard work.
Of course, if you do manage to get access
to a time machine, you can always fall back
on the old “Sports Almanac Retirement Plan.”
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to Google for supporting PBS Digital Studios.
Their mobile app, Science Journal lets you take notes and measure scientific phenomena  such as
light, sound, and motion, using your phone, tablet or Chromebook.
You can find activity ideas and additional information on their website at g.co/sciencejournal